I mean I know what it's gonna taste like
hi
my name is Steven that's Andrew that's
Adam and today we are going to eat it
three ice cream parlors at three
drastically different price points to
find out which one is the most worth it
at a given price hey you vanilla kind of
guy yeah I am of course you are what
does that mean it's basic ice cream
observation vanilla is delicious it's
not plain vanilla gets weird just say
once you've said it a few times in a row
the first place we're going to is call
it fosters freeze they do soft-serve ice
cream and they have two flavors
chocolate vanilla or you want party time
you mix them together I guess it is a
third flavor
what is that College - chocolates choc
Anila but chocolate how do you feel
about ice cream here oh I like the
mascot my name is Isabelle I'm at Foster
Friess and I've been working here for
about 11 years Foster's freeze is kind
of like in LA yes it is a pool right my
location here at eat Gerlach it's been
here for about 55 years already did you
grow up eating Foster's fries yes at
this one at this one the slammer I'm
also a little bit lactose intolerant
that makes two of us all right to enjoy
the ice cream up what is the most
popular thing that Foster's makes I dip
cones we have chocolate vanilla and the
twist 5050 of another chocolate my
technique to get that little stroll on
the top once it's down go round
and then we go ahead and just dip it in
the chocolate and the ice cream doesn't
fall in a cliff just keeping it upside
down if I see up coming up pull it back
up Steven is not allowed to do that I
would like to have a half and a half
tones one day gonna be a big day of
brain freeze I'm gonna get brain freezes
my brain is too powerful for those not
how that works the dipping it's like a
Hershey's bar put on top of the ice
cream
don't break my truck would just throw
not break the gentle touch
that's so good that is so good I'm
usually the kind of guy I'd rather just
buy a tub of ice cream you needed I play
self at home like a economically wise
sad person this is really taking that
ice cream to a next level here brain
freeze you have barely had any ice cream
I know I just have a weak brain I do
love how the chocolate protects me with
an edible skin for the ice cream don't
compare the skin and this ice cream is
actually lighter than most ice cream
y'all get but it's still packed with
that flavor if you go to fosters free
smell is the way to go
he's more of like an old-fashioned
vanilla kind of taste he's a part of my
napkin I think I just took a bite out of
an accident is the most disgusting thing
I've ever seen just down here it1 dude
3d you're gonna get a brain freeze I
already know what's gonna happen this is
a bad idea
[Music]
how's that going oh that place wins it's
not over yet it's like 40 degrees out
how is it not peaceful
I can already feel the ice-cream
churning in my stomach as my body
springs at me for consuming too much
milk check out my new air freshener you
like it no what's wrong with this you
ready for this ice cream pack lay it on
me
the Guinness world record for the
tallest ice cream was made in Norway in
2015 and guess how Paul was 23 10 feet
and 1.2 6 inches Wow did they do it
outside they must have but then it's so
cold in Norway you don't have to worry
about it melt that he couldn't do that
in Mexico you could in a refrigerator I
think you gotta get a better 10 foot
tall refrigerator yeah yes that's not
gonna happen you have to go to Norway so
we're on our way right now to a place
caught scoops this guy is down from
creating the most crazy
Frankenstein concoctions it might be
weird it might be cool
we'll find out scoops
[Music]
welcome to scoops Jonathan Kim nephew of
tycoon today we're gonna be trying out
different types of ice cream how did
scoops get started when I was in
culinary school like I was working at
the storeroom and then we have a small
ice cream maker in front of the store so
I was experiment with a lot of things
I've been doing since 1999 you guys make
all your own flavors here yes all the
base is based on like a creme anglaise
which is like milk sugar is the egg we
use a heavy cream and we put that in the
Machine and then the Machine kind does
everything for us and then we add the
toppings we add the toppings
hyleri like a lasagna told you the ice
cream topping ice cream talking so and
we get you a scoop it's the full of my
topics I noticed over here there's one
called coffee Cuban cigar you want up
like a people customer actually into
Cuba so I asked him to bring cigars so I
made seeker ice cream and what and then
you become one of my favorite because I
do like the so much flavor in this cigar
that's actually really good yeah that
one is really good look grown man eating
that one do you have a favorite flavor
model actually brown bread there's 18
flavors every day but there's one that
doesn't change which is brown but it's
really crunchy because of the great nuts
they don't really go soggy oh it's
heaven yeah they really stay crunchy I
think we're gonna try the brown bread
with the maple looks properly that's
considered a one scoop that's a or one
scoop which is two flavors what do you
eat there's the black truffle one what
that's on the bottom for me yeah well no
if you didn't have these spoons in the
way eat the brown bread alright god
luxurious vanilla ice cream with little
crunchy bits in it I'm amazed at how
crunchy it stays it's honestly a perfect
combination
I love crunch sofas I used to flip shits
in my burger
it's just like something about I thought
you were gonna say that you used to chew
on rocks what is the base flavor vanilla
I think so you vanilla is the best base
ice cream flavor now we're onto the
black truffle I'm very happy that
truffles made into a worth an episode
about yeah you didn't plan that did you
did you or did I did he that's really
good you go truffle is honestly the last
thing I would think to put in ice cream
but it makes sense with something that's
creamy like this you know it doesn't
really taste like truffle it's kind of
like an exam or exotic vanilla that's it
I think this is my work that winter no I
was gonna say it you can come wanting
ice cream but you can still be surprised
by a fun new flavor like I had no idea
that tobacco was gonna be somewhere on
the menu it's all about creating the
experiences here yeah you know I'm
placed through here scoobadood ah scoop
of the day best ice cream I've had all
day
yeah that was kind of a magical
experience all right
so this weekend you need Adam take a
flight to New York City city of dreams
city of concrete jungles and King Kong
actually King Kong is in Tokyo right and
we're gonna try out know Godzilla's in
Tokyo King Kong is in New York so oh I
had it right the first time
dang it we're gonna try out the most
expensive ice cream in existence
[Music]
we're here in City I'm tired now the air
feels uh it's frustrating
I like that city stink so we just flew
from LA to New York City try this one
item of food serendipity threes $1,000
ice cream yeah
hi I'm Joe Calderon we're here in
serendipity 3 in New York City
serendipity 3 it was founded in 1954 as
the first kind of coffee shop boutique
in New York and we're gonna be making
the golden opulence sundae the $1,000
ice cream Wow Saudi princes have come to
indulge to celebrities to a father
bringing his daughter to congratulate
her graduating law school
$2,000 yes why how it's the best of the
best ingredients the ice cream is housed
in a Baccarat crystal goblet that you
get to take home with you we take three
scoops of this specially made to he-she
manila ice cream we infuse it with
Madagascar vanilla to really get this
incredible vanilla flavor we played it
with 23-karat edible gold top that with
chocolate sauce that we make out of the
world's most expensive chocolate and the
rarest chocolate we add the candied
fruit from cow Sean and Paris
top it with the sugar flour and then we
have a tiny bowl of the world's only
dessert caviar it's a salt free caviar
that's infused with passion fruit and
arm yak it has a nice little bite and it
works so well with the sundae it's an
edible piece of art that's what we call
it yeah when you want to start with you
want to try that way spring first this
is incredible I mean this is beautiful
I like that the glass isn't gold though
it makes sense because then you can see
I can't take you anywhere I'm gonna
start eating the ice cream all right
like cheers says it's melting with all
that hot air coming out of your mouth
when I pull away and get a scoop this
sheets of gold break apart and turning
to Justin glittery bites of ice cream
truly is a work of art got some mostly
gold Cheers
[Music]
oh the vanilla bean is it weird for me
to say that gold goes well with ice
cream doesn't really have much of a
taste but the texture of like soapy gold
going in your mouth it is best on a very
cold substance that ice cream is amazing
I'm gonna have a little piece of
chocolate here put a jelly bean do you
hear that amazing is that a jelly bean
yes in the thousand dollars Sunday they
use jelly beans
Steve Edna from to have some dessert
caviar you throw me some I can place you
some indie
oh wow that's not what I expected
it is like salted caramel in ice cream
nothing here is too rich
I feel wrong eating this really I think
so right can I take a bite of the gold
leaf how is that so cool I love this
because it brings out that child joy
that's like the overall experience that
serendipity through though walking into
a child's oh you know I had to happen
sooner or later
no it didn't it did what are you doing
you just put your hand in my ice cream
also I'm on so much sugar right now
Andrew got us up having ice cream for
breakfast yeah never gonna happen
there was like $150 version of that I
would get that regularly that's a lie
ice cream and caviar is my new favorite
thing so we had three different ice
creams across two different cities which
ice cream was the most worth it at its
price on a hot summer day just wrapped
up at the beach foster's freeze is the
place I would go to first the flavors
you get it scoops
that's my worth it win Wow Cuban cigar
coffee ice cream that's the next level
it just kind of expands your mind in a
way that food kind of really does I felt
like a little kid this entire trip
eating ice cream for breakfast lunch
dinner come on I bring you the best
oh he's they got puppies
Oh
[Music]
worth it serendipity oh my god
that whole experience changed my life
tastes more like but it was a thousand
dollars and I don't typically have a
thousand dollars on me all that being
said I think I'm gonna have to go with
Foster's phrase the classic flavors the
ones you want and the value on that is
insane that to me is the epitome of ice
cream Adam is just scoops I don't know
what we're gonna do now eat something
eat real food all right we're done I
know that people are gonna look at this
pizza and say it's burnt what are you
thinking about though it's gonna say
that
[Music]
oh yes